mr. Garrett white welcome to modern
wisdom how are you today sir
wonderful I brought all my gray bearded
hair on my chin to represent the modern
wisdom game you know modern hair gray
facial hair
I think he's qualifies me to be here
that's the equivalent the facial
equivalent of smart casual yeah exactly
Garrett for the listeners who don't know
who you are can you give us a bit of
background please absolutely so I'm
mouth for two different books one book
I'll be the man which we have available
in Amazon and we have tens of thousands
copies of this book actually going out
every single month and a book called
warrior book which is its partner book
these two together represent an
organization and a movement called wake
up warrior which is a lifestyle for
businessmen particularly married
businessmen around the globe and we have
clients in 27 countries and we have been
some thousands of men that travelled to
us with thousands of clients online
inside of our membership sites and our
experiences but the whole premise is how
can a man actually access power while at
the same time continuing to produce
across all areas of his life how can I
bring my body my being my balance along
with business production and not have
them be mutually exclusive
Wow so you're trying to raise the
consciousness and the performance of men
as you put it yes the New York Post when
they interviewed us about one of our
programs called worry week here at last
it was actually 2016 they did a huge
write-up for us and a couple other
people that were interviewing as a
couple people come out and documents
from all documentaries inside of our
events they all kind of coin the same
phrase and they spun off of what New
York Post is which is the wake up
warrior is the initiator of the industry
of masculinity like be when I started
talking about this people been talking
about it there's articles Gillette's
done a media play on it people dabble
with it churches dabble with it
religions dabble with it politicians
dabble with it there's been groups that
have come up mostly run by by Christian
organizations trying to inspire men to
be something but Waco Boyer came along
and said hey listen we're a bunch of
businessmen and we know there's a better
way because the way we're doing it isn't
[ __ ]
working and things need to be different
we don't do it as nice as the Gillette
commercial and have guys sitting in a
row and talking through it and although
the principles inside of that are true
the nature of warrior is far more
aggressive in our approach at pulling it
out because we're not actually at where
we're hunting down alpha males and
ultimately helping men all men recognize
that when I say hunting down alpha males
where everyone is an alpha male like in
your world every single [ __ ] minute
walks the planet is an alpha male even
if you're a guy who's behind a keyboard
all day long and you think you're not
and you're looking at Chris and you're
like he's a goddamn fitness model he
looks amazing I wished I had a body
where my underwear like that on
Instagram but you're like [ __ ] I don't
want to even [ __ ] wear my underwear
in front of the mirror by myself let
alone look like I want to be like Chris
listen even if you subscribe to the dad
bod game underneath that for you is
something bigger and that's really what
that's really what we're pursuing single
married doesn't matter the message is
the same you're a man stop lying
start leading and the way you lead is
you stop lying so what are the common
speed bumps or the principal problems
that you think that men are facing at
the moment either from themselves or
from external influences so I I mean I
went along this path I grew up in a
pretty aggressive environment my
environment was aggressive like we
didn't come up with money I didn't come
up with so there was a like the hustler
make [ __ ] happen game was part of my
experience but you just figured [ __ ] out
if you had a problem you [ __ ] fought
if you didn't have a problem you didn't
fight and even if you had a problem
maybe you didn't have a problem you
still probably fought but nonetheless
like there was just this this thing of
dealing and we were taught I was taught
my dad was a very passive guy my mom
aggressive as hell my dad a passive guy
my dad was like a pillow guy and my mom
was like a butcher knife so like my mom
would like Ginsu the flour the feathers
out of my dad's pillow all the time so
my representation of life of what it was
to be a man was brought to me by my
mother
aggressive alpha woman like how Barnette
my my intensity comes from my mom not
from my dad my dad's exact opposite so
as always raised
I was learning intensity from my mother
I was learning intensity from the street
I was learning intensity from just being
with guys and along that I learned a
whole bunch other [ __ ] which is one
don't actually tell the truth why
because the whole truth of what's really
going on inside of you most people can't
handle the you look somebody in a badger
City go to London we look at some
homeless people walking down the street
go Newcastle find a homeless guy walking
down the street they're typically saying
all the [ __ ] that we're thinking in our
heads by people looking I go to New York
City and you look at a homeless guy and
people will be saying crazy stuff to be
walking down the street and saying
things I was like oh my god that guy's
crazy I was like no no if we could
actually broadcast with a bow speaker
what goes on inside your fucked-up head
all day long about women walking by
about your wife about your business
about your boss about the people you
work with so your clients your and your
smoger like hey but inside you I got
[ __ ] hate this client this [ __ ]
better [ __ ] pay this time young man
supers it's okay it's okay and inside
there's another truth so I sorted down
and found that recognizing that it
wasn't safe to be all of me I was told
always tone it down you're too loud
you're too aggressive you're too intense
and Society started teaching me to tone
it down so while my mom was an
aggressive alpha my mom doesn't have a
penis open up yeah crazy like my mom's
got a penis and a vagina right I don't
even know they called it something so
like my mom no matter what she tried to
do was not a man my dad was not teaching
me how to be a man my dad never shared
his feelings my dad never talked about
serious [ __ ] with us my dad my dad
didn't have that comment he's not a bad
person
my dad was raised in a military family
my grandfather was a colonel in the Air
Force my Broncos were all military hard
my whole family military military well
in that place your is no safe place in
the military for feelings so my dad was
taught feelings do not exist for you
so don't tell the truth when I say light
it's it we lie about what we're feeling
there's no room for you to admit your
scared growing up there's no room as a
guy to be like eh yeah dude I'm [ __ ]
terrified right now or man I'm feeling
really emotionally [ __ ] up about this
girl I don't even know how to talk about
it the only time that kind of truth to
come out is after a couple of pints now
of a sudden boys start talking so I
didn't have a roadmap for how to deal
with feelings which is what the Gillette
commercials saying right now which is
like listen man you need to like
intercept other men who are doing [ __ ]
up things and our society has become a
function of what men are and men are not
doing that's a good point that is a
really good point the fact that the onus
is still on men I think a lot here and
that's one of the undercurrents that is
often missed when people start to talk
about misogynist movement or a feminist
movement with that that it's up to men
to fix men is the the message that's
being put across at the moment but that
still leaves the power in the hands of
men they like it that if that's not
reinforcing a patriarchy I don't really
know what is in whatever form it could
be so you talked about truth and it's
something that we talk about a lot on
the on the show for me truth has been a
good path for me to try and find virtue
and integrity which is something that I
can feel proud of myself about how do
you mediate a level of truthfulness
which is effective and allows you to be
useful and and move forward of lis
whilst not compromising on your virtue
and your integrity right so I think if
you if you look at it if I if I step
back and I look at what like what is
what is the undercurrent of the problem
okay we have we have a label of what a
man is supposed to be that has been
identified okay there are two versions
of this that have been identified and a
third that's trying to creep its way in
the first one is shredded ripped alpha
aggressive angry lobster athlete
politician get [ __ ] done at all costs
right so there's this alpha guy who
instantly enough Society actually
supports that guy women say they want a
different guy but their behaviors
actually don't represent that they don't
represent that they go after you
younger women women don't tend to pursue
security until they're in their 30s
about in their 30s they start to say yes
and I don't give a [ __ ] about your
12-pack what I need is money and I need
support financially I need you this is
why you've got women in their thirties
hooking up with men in their 50s because
the men and their fifties got the money
and they don't give a [ __ ] about the
hairy back hairy ass and the [ __ ]
gold chains they got cash so they're
like okay I'd this makes sense to me I'm
looking for security in your twenties
they just want to get [ __ ] and want to
get laid and they want to have that
conversation they want to be they want
to be taken care of but there's there's
a message coming from society from women
that's confusing them into men exists in
this alpha place but then there's
another version which creeped up over
the last couple decades which is this
softer spoken it very in touch with
their feelings amazing guys but they're
the complete opposite into the spectrum
these are the guys sitting around
campfires playing guitars singing
rubbing oil on themselves meditating
doing desert walks hanging out with
shamans there and there right and the
problem is the Alpha message the message
in this third man is coming from that
right side it's coming from soft-spoken
men who are saying listen we need to
change some things we can do this woosah
and all the guys on the other side are
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up and if any woman tells man they need
to change which women have been trying
to do it but women are sending confusing
messages to because women at the same
time are starting to get to a place
where like we don't even [ __ ] need
you guys like we really don't even need
you we got bumble if we want to get laid
we could just hook up with any guy we
want controls in our side tinder
pocket we can go get what we want we're
entitled to getting paid which I agree I
don't have a problem of those two things
but for the last 35 years we've had this
empowerment of women and actually a
disempowerment of training in men with
only one of two options be a doormat guy
and talk about vision boards and
disappear into the desert in the jungle
and do tapas AMA
meditation with a 95 other female yoga
instructors
or I'm in an aggressive world of
cutthroat business and MMA and hardcore
CrossFit Games and throw some weight
around and [ __ ] overhead overhead
squat like 350 I need you're that guy or
I'm like oh yeah in the Sun what you
mean so we've got this polar at this
polarization of men from one side which
is very very very typically masculine to
one side which is more emotionally
intelligent and has has a softer
approach now yes where does where does
the perfect man lie for yourself where's
the most effective way he has to have
the ability to go to both at all times
so are you saying that the man that's an
alpha male is less effective than a man
that's an alpha male with the
opportunity to go to the mindfulness the
emotional intelligence so on and so
forth we're saying that a modern warrior
man encompasses the greatness in both
sides so I walk down the street my wife
wants to know I can [ __ ] some people up
if [ __ ] happens
[ __ ] goes down my wife wants a man who
can go dark code-nine pick up a [ __ ]
two wood piece of wood protect our
family and [ __ ] some people up in a
parking lot okay every woman wants to be
protected but at the same time when I
come home from the office and being like
[Applause]
she also wants to know I can come in I
can sit down and I can listen to middle
school drama from my daughter and her
friends and I can sit and read stories
about the bunny who doesn't know what he
wants in life and if he should be a
moose or if he should be a beaver or if
he should be a pig and at the end finds
out he just really wants to be a bunny
and I can lay down and play some music
and tickle my 7 year olds back while she
falls asleep and that shows up to the my
wife's three months pregnant and comes
to the ultrasounds and sits in quiet
control and deep emotional intimacy with
my wife while we're looking at this new
thing that's being created inside of her
while at the same time expects me
go get [ __ ] paid yeah so and then
expects me to come home and be available
to her feelings and at the same time
[ __ ] some people up in a parking lot
thirty seconds later if right after our
feeling conversation some hoodlums show
up in some [ __ ] goes down you need to go
Tom Clancy Rainbow six yeah totally I
totally understand so why do you think
that there is this kind of bipartisan
movement where you have an all or
nothing so I often talk about the fact
that as a human being we're creatures of
absolutes right so it's easy if I pass
you a packet of biscuits and I say
you're allowed to eat none of them are
you're allowed to eat all of them both
of those decisions are actually quite
easy or as if I say you're allowed to
have one biscuit and then you've got to
roll the packet back up and put it away
that's really quite hard and that's the
messy middle as as is often the
situation the devil is in the details
and the subtlety and the nuance of the
the most optimal level is a little bit
of everything it's a balanced life right
it's all of the the best parts of
everything whilst not overdoing to hit
the worst parts of an overdose so is
that the reason why it's people are
identifying your men seem to be
identifying with one camp or another or
is it just easier it's easier I mean
what are the two things that we can
control right I as a guy really can
control your body can control your money
so this why these
to conversations men drift to the
easiest get fit get paid get laid get
fit hopefully get laid and if I'm fit
hopefully I'll get me get paid and if
I'm not fit but I get paid I'll probably
still get laid so [ __ ] the fitness I'll
just get paid and get laid
which is really what a default sound to
which at the end of the day is laid now
getting laid is not just about penis and
vagina I'm talking about like the
ability for a man to feel wanted and to
be in relationship and communion with a
feminine woman who he wants to be in
relationship with right so there's this
desire that we have studied over the
last seven years and prior to that the
five years previous and studying myself
and now tens of thousands of men we have
studied on this conversation not just
like we read some data like in the ditch
in the trench through our worry week
events or warrior conventions everything
watching studying data in our min of
watching the patterns from 27 countries
and they're all the same which is at the
end of the day a man wants to be wanted
but inside of our current society there
is no definition of what it is to be a
man this was my wife screaming at me to
be the man that's how the cover of the
book the title of the book even existed
I didn't come up with some marketing
approach my wife literally was yelling
at me I didn't sign up for this [ __ ] why
can't you just be the man what was she
referring to she had no one yeah she had
no idea I had no idea what that was
that's a great question what was she
referring to this is what spun me out
Chris cuz I was like be the man and when
I looked out guess what I saw I saw two
examples of be the man I saw example of
overbearing get the money our hungry
tyrant I knew that guy I'd been that guy
and then I saw this other path which I
spent three and a half years in which
was barefoot growing my hair out walking
around literally public bathrooms no
shoes that's disgusting but I was doing
it because I was like literally three
years walking around meditating thinking
that the greatest thing in life even
better than an orgasm was a sense of
connection and healing that I was
feeling working with all these women and
I worked with all women were just my
coaches for three and half years didn't
coach any man I actually got scared of
guys which was weird because I had
become so tapped into my feminine side
I'd forgotten the Alpha I've gone to the
other extreme and then I woke up their
nose
this does not work so I'm sitting in the
middle with my wife screaming at me be
the man she didn't consider like
meditation guy be the man she also
despised the aggressive alpha guy
because I would only swing from one side
to the other
I was either putting my hand on her
chest and I was like look at me I want
to deeply connect with you she's like
you're [ __ ] weird stop leukemia or I
was on the other side and I'm like hey
listen I know it's 10 o'clock do you
want to [ __ ] right now yeah she's like
no and I'm like damn it I can't seem to
I'd just unplugged my own camera we're
all good no the middle the middle game
of being the man was really what I that
was that was how worry was born finding
me was literally answer that question
yes totally
okay so you've mentioned it a couple of
times worried a week what is it
the experience of what we teach about in
our books right it's like like the the
educational front of where I like the
cover of be the man says stop lying
start leading today on people said well
what does that mean it's very simple men
cannot be free if they're not free to be
all of who they are this means that
there is a lot of who you are that's not
acceptable the people you currently run
with not acceptable
and so you mask and hide those
characteristics you filter them back
this is the problem you get into a
relationship either so many divorces
because most of us get in relationship
driven by only showing a part of who we
actually are while masking the other
part of what we really got going on in
our mind and so people like well ha ha
how are there's so many divorces because
we have so many [ __ ] liars who get in
relationship and fall in love with a
story of only half of a story but then
you get married and then things start to
get into it that what they are and then
six seven years down the road you kind
of verdun trying to impress and you're
like [ __ ] this and so the whole part of
you comes out and then you're like oh my
god that's ugly and disgusting I want
nothing to do with that part of you so
as society even Instagram Instagram is a
perfect example it sounds like we're
going on there and posting pictures of
us taking a [ __ ] hey here's me taking a
[ __ ] and then the next photo is like
phong back girl at the beach same
thought
that girl taking a [ __ ] this morning
like a disgusting nasty [ __ ] came out of
that girl's ass and you're all upon her
ass with a picture like huh [ __ ] look
at that ass yeah that same ass was
[ __ ] a giant log the size of this
[ __ ] Russian doll this morning
because she was constipated for the last
three days that same woman has periods
and it gets nasty and guess what so do
you you stinky bastards and Chris looks
like a goddamn male model but if he does
just shower he smells like [ __ ] too so
all of us are in this place where we
have pieces of us that we don't accept
about ourselves men on one side don't
accept the fact that dude like they
actually want to connect with other men
not sexually but in intimate
relationships like dude I want to like
actually be able to talk to you for real
I don't want to talk to you about sports
and who the next runner up for the
CrossFit Games championship is is rich
froning's gonna come back and he's gonna
do some cool [ __ ] listen he's a goddamn
demigod across all right awesome and you
know what not a goddamn thing he does
Donald Trump does or anyone else does is
actually going to change how you feel
about yourself and that's Chris you and
I be able to sit say it dude listen man
here's a reality like this is my friend
a coupled a couple weeks ago super
shredded dude super [ __ ] the athlete
and he's like man I got eating disorder
bro he's like I'm [ __ ] he's like you
see all this [ __ ] but I'm jacked I think
about food all day long man he's like
I'm a [ __ ] prisoner to my [ __ ] 12
back I was like I get it like I do and
he's that but if you walk around and the
women in this county love him and
they're like that dude is sex on a stick
oh my god and I'm like dude you are a
walking suicide mission and he has no
one to talk to my wife and I get text
messages from so many people I get them
every week from people in our family
friends we're like my husband's leaving
I'm leaving my husband hey I've had this
problem I cheated on my spouse and if
people tell us he what because coming to
us there is no judgement and why is
there no judgment because I stopped
beating the [ __ ] out of myself for being
a human being I'm a man who loves my
wife and at times I have a part of me
that wants to [ __ ] everything that walks
by like this is a fact and it is a fact
of being a
man on the part penis like I've been
genetically wired this way whether I act
on that or not as it totally different
thing
but there's an acceptance so stage one
in this warrior weak be the man inside
of our programs or online systems
everything we do is about helping a man
come to terms with listen you've been
lying about worry then you've been lying
about what you've done you're lying
about where you are and you're lying
about where you want to go like what
changed my marriage was me acknowledging
that I married a woman who was very
different than what I anticipated how so
Shh I had a desire for a particular type
of woman yet I married a different type
of one my wife is very controlled she's
not touchy-feely she's not huggy
she's not gonna cuddle with me in bed
but guess what most aggressive alpha
guys to the marketplace guess what they
really are they're guys wanna cuddle and
be told they're good and have a head on
their chest and be told they're the man
and have some some woman rub their
nipple and they want to feel amazing
about themselves like most of the
swollen buff tad - guys I know they're
[ __ ] horribly lost inside its
compensating completely overcompensating
forgot so inside of that place like I
saw myself in a relationship with I
wanted connection I wanted to be wanted
I wanted to have no weirdness and
sexuality in my marriage but I was
married to a woman that I was like the
comparison I was sitting down on a bench
with my wife and we were talking three
years ago and I said listen here's what
I've come to understand you're a cat and
my whole life I wanted dog and it's been
absolutely unfair of me for 10 11 years
of marriage to expect you to bark but I
also have to decide if I'm okay with
spending the rest of my life with a cat
and she's like what does that mean I was
like listen you know exactly what that
means you're not happy like I was
pushing for greatness in my marriage and
wake up or he was already moving and I
told that I was very open with all our
student days I said there is a couple
pieces in my marriage I'm hunting down
and I will not stop and I was
wake up where you're down and I will go
public about the fact that I have not
been able to find the formula but I am
going to push my marriage to a place
where I believe it can be hold the same
way my business my body and my being is
or I will fail and the habit of
lifestyle is a lie and so that was a
crucial moment for us and we sat on that
and then my wife and I got to make new
decisions we actually separated for like
three weeks and I said listen maybe you
need to date some other guys I figure
some [ __ ] out for yourself like you've
been with me since you were young I know
I'm a very different person now than
what I used to be I'm not gonna tell
myself down I'm not gonna stop
pretending that I don't have darkness
I'm a fucked-up guy I got some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in my head I understand that and
I'm dealing with it I'm processing I'm
working on it every day and I also know
that I will go to war if this is what
you want to do if you want to if we want
to go to war together to build a
marriage that works
we're gonna go to 15 years let's do this
like I want to do this I don't wanna get
divorced because getting divorced we
know Zack was gonna happen to be right
back in a stupid game again and names
are gonna change we're just gonna find a
different person to [ __ ] it up with
because nothing's changed with us she's
like okay so she leaves for three weeks
and we're sitting there for three weeks
when we make some decisions and we both
decide that life might be easier not
married to each other
I might get laid a whole lot more and my
wife might have a whole lot less
insanity from a crazy psychopath like me
and then she said but there's no
guarantee that our life will be any
better she's like so I'm all-in I said
me too
let's go so but but to have those kind
of conversations to be able to actually
knowledge you have to be able to have
them with yourself for years I was
confronting in myself like truths that I
did not want to look at I was raised in
Mormonism I left that religion ten years
ago when I walked out of that faith this
was not like leaving a religion this was
like leaving my life my eternal life
according to the entire culture I had
been raised and I was divided and hated
and called the Antichrist to a point I
almost went to physical blows with my
father because what I was doing was in
such threat to the whole family and I
didn't know how to deal so my wife and I
were completely alone like I was so
committed to living a life where I did
not worry
about you finding something out about me
there's no TMZ good [ __ ] luck you're
gonna find anything I don't already
publish on youtube so [ __ ] off you mean
somebody's gonna release some [ __ ] about
me on the Internet whoo I got some scary
details about Garrett [ __ ] you I've
already put it online and I've made it
very easy for you to find so if you're
wondering about [ __ ] I'm up to just
Google what a [ __ ] geared up to and
you'll [ __ ] find it so each one is in
war week stage one on anything in the
conversation a warrior is coming to
grips with the idea that you're a liar I
like incoming Tudor what it would take
to tell the truth I like the fact that
you focusing on truth here it's
something that we talk an awful lot
about and Sam Harris's book lying is the
absolute Bible as far as I'm concerned
for this for anyone who is listening I
recommend that you get it it's about an
hour hour long read or an hour and 20
minute audio book and it really did
change my my opinion on that now some of
the listeners as well will know what I'm
probably about to quote now which is my
favorite video from Alain de Botton on
the School of Life and it's a video
called why we are fated to be lonely and
in that he talks about what you've
identified there which is given the
choice between honesty and acceptability
most of us will choose the latter
because our ideas are too alarming too
subtle or too nuanced to be understood
by society at large and when you have
the a lot of the time we will be how is
it that he puts it he says we draw a
connection with someone not because we
know that we can have a proper
conversation but because we were once so
faithfully drawn to the shape of their
nose and the color of their eyes and
what you've said there is that we have
this immediate desire for physical
connection and we then mold ourselves
into an acceptable form of what we think
that person wants from us and over time
as that relationship begins to mature
like keeping up a lie
living a lie for five or ten of 20 years
is exhausting and yet eventually it'll
start to break down and then that's what
happens so is as far as you're concerned
is honesty a super power is the ability
to be honest with yourself and with
others a foundation foundational power
that everything's built on
yeah I think in our society today it is
a superpower like it is and the problem
with it being a super virus not just a
superpower it's a weapon and it's a
declaration of war like I don't even
know who to quote on this somebody sent
me a little audio I don't even know
where the [ __ ] came from like one of
my guys sent me an audio and I was
listening to it on a rock in warrior
week I was heading up the hill to where
our where our students were out are 25
guys with my seven trainers inside of a
deep inside the mountain in one of our
evolutions and I'm listening to this
audio over and over and over again and
it went but when it basically like this
then in the land of liars the truth is a
weapon and when spoken is a declaration
of war so like we live in such [ __ ]
political correctness trying to make
everybody happy trying to keep
everything in balance trying to keep
everything socially acceptable with the
foundation of society that are ridden in
a muck pile of [ __ ] and lies we lie
to ourselves every day we lie to our
children we lie to our partners we lie
to our mothers we lie to our family we
lied to 1 because we lie it ourselves
and so inside of all this we're trying
to say well you've change people will
say this when someone starts to speak
the truth they're like what you've
changed well no I didn't change I'm
actually for the very first time telling
you the full story and so I apologize
we've been a relationship you've had
chapters 1 through 5 but I've got 6
through 10 and I've hid that I ripped
that book and half stuck that other than
that backpack and you've been reading
chapters 1 through 5 the six year ten is
the rest of this story and while it
began hot and fresh and filled with
light and possibility and I brought you
flowers every Tuesday guess what I'm a
[ __ ] crazy guy also who does some
crazy [ __ ] in the dark
that you don't even know about that I'm
embarrassed about because I don't accept
that about myself so yeah it's a
superpower to tell the truth because
it's painful it's painful because
society doesn't support the truth
society persecutes the truth and human
beings persecute truth tellers and they
hide and they reject it and they
personally good if there's a very first
thing we do as somebody who speaks the
truth about themselves is it exposes the
other person Chris you tell the truth
and if I'm a liar and I'm in
relationship with you and you start
becoming super
about your [ __ ] but I'm guarded with my
[ __ ] immediately I'm forced into a
decision and my decision is I either
need to shut you the [ __ ] up and I need
to manipulate you to just stop talking
about that or I have to expose myself or
I have to end our relationship
so you either got to shut up I gotta put
up or I got to get out and so when you
when you it's it is very difficult
because when you do this you're now
declaring that inside of all my
relationships here's the reality they
are all built on lies which means you're
my friend but you don't actually know me
you're my spouse but you don't actually
know me you're my employer or I am for
you work for me and you don't actually
know me and you know what that's on me
that's on me for having the courage to
own my truth but see you know guys
aren't like [ __ ] with something we're
trying to do this we were raised to do
this our society taught us do not tell
the truth do not be do not express your
feelings you are alone in your
experience and even our own guy circles
if a man expressed vulnerability or any
sense of expression of a pain in that
men don't know how to deal with it and
they immediately will try to silence it
bro bro you're all right [ __ ] that [ __ ]
bro
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you all right bro come
on you good don't worry about it you're
good hey do you know what do we worry
about the bro you got why cuz they
weren't trained either so we have an
entire generation of men now women
raising up most men in the United States
on an autism UK but here in the United
States most women raising their children
we have a higher single mother rate in
the United States we've ever had in a
country's history mothers leading men
how to be men my alpha mom tried to
teach me so we have generational now
guidance coming from women teaching men
how to be men and women sang men be the
man with men sang oh [ __ ] uh-uh I don't
know what that is and so you try and
then you get shot that's not it you
[ __ ] well
nope that's not it the only message that
it's clear is this if you make money we
listen to you
you want to beat our entire message in
the worldwide to men it is one simple
thing and it transcends your 30 when
you're 40 people won't give a [ __ ] about
your body bro they won't they'll care
about one thing do you have power and
power doesn't come down to your physical
body power comes down to your money your
money and your influence so we have this
whole generation of Millennials who are
in their 20s telling this new story and
I love it
but the entire be Millennial Generation
is confused as [ __ ] - they know that
shit's broken they know it's broken
that's why they need to fight but they
have no answers then that that although
highly connected my children highly
connected in this [ __ ] goddamn prison
that sits right here highly connected
yet completely and utterly emotionally
incapable of dealing with actual human
interaction and engagement this phone is
a [ __ ] prison and at the same time a
paradise and so the next generation
isn't any better which means our young
men are coming up and they at least have
a better attitude than our generation
did which is like [ __ ] the Machine do
this [ __ ] is not working I'm gonna live
my passion I'm gonna live my purpose I
am NOT subscribed in society's [ __ ]
I may not even go to university I'm not
add to Phi 2 Phi Gary Vaynerchuk style
and then you're like okay good so help
me understand what you're gonna do about
it so they asked Siri
let me ask Siri real quick Oh Siri how
do I be the man searching searching so
if I make if I if tomorrow we were able
to make Garrett white in charge of
culture president of culture and
president possession for the globe
president of culture for the globe yep
international international president of
culture what would you lay out I want to
hear what you feel like moving forward
whether we are
in a situation of despair or one of hope
and what the what the steps and what the
plan would be that you would deploy to
the UN so that men and women would
better be able to understand how they
can have an effective relationship with
each other what would you do step one is
you approach the leaders and what are
you force you force leaders to face the
truth about themselves like the end like
I force fear I forward people to face
their own [ __ ]
not not society not culture not Nations
leaders there's why he brought in and
work with CEOs right now I get brought
in to work with high end executives
running half a billion a billion dollar
companies for what for one reason
because they know that their entire
organization is driven by the
willingness they have to stand in truth
and they know their executive CFO CEO
CFO CEO OS CTOs all the organizational
leaders if they're liars it trickles
down trickled down why your leadership
is our problem
so everybody wants to start with a
message the bottom on the way up but
that's not like that works at a certain
level but until people listen tell and
tell leaders in powerful positions
listen to some of the [ __ ] that Gary
saying it doesn't [ __ ] matter how
many twenty year olds listen my
Lamborghini is awesome because there's
so many YouTube kids now who drive
Lambos and so every [ __ ] kid under
the age of 15 can't even help it when I
Drive by they don't do it about Ferraris
why because younger generation YouTube
well guess what not everyone can be a
YouTube rockstar I don't give a [ __ ] how
many times people try to preach that
ain't gonna happen it's not going to
happen 99.9% of people who started
YouTube channel will never make enough
money to do it so you have this
generation and then looking for guidance
step one is face your own [ __ ] that
culture cannot exist outside of the
culture of you
my family is a function of me as a man
my business is a function of me as a man
which means it starts with me so the
first step is I will gut myself in front
of everybody and in a room of powerful
people sitting in that room I have
nothing to hide
which means now I'm gonna walk around
I'm gonna look at you and I'm a look at
the guy next to you and I'm gonna say
all right listen we're not leaving this
room until we're all clear on one thing
that you're [ __ ] liars and we have a
nation of liars and if we don't solve
our line problems no policy no program
no administration is going to change
[ __ ]
now here's the reality politicians will
never do this and so we went after
businessmen because guess what business
men actually control the game now
politicians I've seen some videos from
worry a week of your trainers
encouraging guys to open up and then I
think they begin to reveal parts of
themselves that they haven't done before
and they push themselves to a place they
haven't been before and based on what
I've seen and some personal experience
as well that very very quickly goes from
alpha male aggression to complete
breakdown and you see lines of men
crying into each others arms and you
have the facade is now gone right Masada
the truth is allowed to live and the
truth is that they are they aggressive
guy but the truth is they're also the
opposite when the truth is they're a
sensitive guy and the truth is they do
give a [ __ ] and the truth is guys at
womanize they don't really want a woman
eyes the ones were raised up in this
[ __ ] they don't they don't but they
don't have any other path who's giving
them a path so we have a society people
telling men like the me2 movement listen
I realize that guys are doing some crazy
[ __ ] I get it I get it guys are doing
stupid [ __ ] all over the place our
school shootings in the u.s. are
happening by men like you don't hear
about women raping men it happens I'm
sure but like prop sexual harassment
doesn't typically come from women to men
it comes from when men to women I'm not
disavowing that but we also have a
society that's rising with a confusing
message constantly too many women say
they want one thing but they act another
way men have no roadmap for how they're
supposed to act in any other way and so
they settled down to this one game and
inside my particular niche is like a man
who
can get honest has no choice when the
facade is exposed to go to break down
but inside a breakdown comes the
opportunity for a man to actually break
through I can't become something new if
I'm stuck in my game right if I don't
change how if I if I'm in CrossFit and
I'm not changing my current form in a
squad snatch right if I'm not if I'm
changing my clean sport if I my elbows
are [ __ ] down and I don't got a great
[ __ ] high pole if you if you continue
to load the weight I can [ __ ] this up
and like hold my back a certain way and
like flax really hard and overdo it and
get into it and still get the weight up
but fundamentally my function is [ __ ]
which means at some point it becomes
impossible to improve and so in order to
go I'm gonna have to actually come back
down from my one rep Max's back down
from what my my rankings were and
actually get worse for a time as I go
back and retrain the myelination
experience inside of my own mind my own
physicality to get me into a place where
I learn a better routine and a better
form and when this happens in
powerlifting a man goes down he gets
worse and then he comes back stronger
and then passes what he did before but
most of us do not want to go down nobody
wants to go from the guy that lifts X
but then you're the guy that lifts Y so
you're better off to stay at the guy
that lifts X and so we have a society
that is stuck at a PR weird of one rep
max and everybody's talking about how
big their [ __ ] is all the [ __ ] here's
your [ __ ] pants bro like the way
you're doing [ __ ] like you're arching
your hips you're all off the mat you got
your feet on the [ __ ] bench you're
doing powerlifting like steroid use
availability type squats and bench press
with like a thousand pounds or like
seventeen belts on with the [ __ ]
nylon suit that's tight enough to encase
the goddamn NASA shuttle and you're set
and you're like nice good [ __ ] and guess
what you can't even [ __ ] walk up the
stairs without losing your breath so
[ __ ] you better get your hands on me
quick cuz I'll be just dancing around
you while you pass out from cardiac
arrest like we have a problem in going
back people don't want to go back they
want to go forward they don't recognize
to go forward you have to go back which
means to break through you have to break
down you have to go low to go high you
have to go into the dark to find light
you don't find light by looking in the
light oh let me go look in the room I
already turn the lights on and let's see
if there's anything new
like somebody walk into the fridge
opening the fridge huh we got any food
in here no okay close ten minutes later
I'm gonna go back to the fridge see if
they're my things might have changed
magically in some magic food elves drop
some [ __ ] off in my fridge Oh nope still
there's nothing in the fridge closed ten
minutes later and then you're just
tolerance goes down and then you eat the
shitty thing in the fridge eternal they
want like we as human beings are not
trained to go backwards we've been
taught to go backwards as bad at warrior
we say listen the only way for you to go
forward is to go backward the only way
for you to break through to have it all
embody being bound some days that's the
only way for the Warriors way to
actually work for you as a man is for
you to go backwards and it feels like
you're going backwards but you're not no
different than a Power lifter that has
to go backwards in form in order to get
function so then it go back to more fire
and actually perform at a higher level
and that's whiskey back go ahead and
that's what you talk about breaking down
and but yeah and getting real with
yourself yes which is what I do my
marriage it's what I had to do as a
father it's what I had to do as a
businessman I had to acknowledge I'm
very good at these things over here and
I am shitty at this how if you're a man
that's listening to this or a woman who
wants to help herself or her
relationship or however it might be
where'd you go from here what the steps
that you start to take because some
people have lived a life is so long that
they don't know what the truth is
anymore yep all for sure and then you
think you know the truth and then you
peel it back and that's why we say that
the truth is actually less about the
truth and more about the facts like we
can look at the facts like you can have
what you think is the truth about your
body
big-boned and I got a gyroid problem
you're like you know I'm big bones you
know thyroid problem you have [ __ ]
eating and a lack of cardio problem so
how about we get to the facts of what's
really happening
well generational my grandma Mildred was
all right no [ __ ] you that's not how it
is how about you get out of your
[ __ ] stories and let's get into the
facts what are the facts how many times
you train this week how much cardio
jadoo or your calorie consumption let's
move to facts instead of your [ __ ]
fantasy stories that you call truth so
the problem with even truth is the truth
will set you free is the truth is like
this variable thing that changes in
everybody's head all the time this is
true no this is true no this is true and
the fitness world is gonna worse at it
this is the right way this is the right
way well we did some more studies and we
found out the mitochondria that there's
blah you're like [ __ ] off you guys are
all right at some level so we get to the
facts and the guys okay well how do I
get to the facts how do i how do I
actually start with this well first it
comes with the desire the only reason
somebody would go through this and the
only reason a man would actually take
this approach was because he recognizes
his life right now it's not working and
your life is not working one of two ways
either your life truly is not working
like you're in a broken-down situation
it's just not working you're like I
brought to try something that was me
like my life literally was working was
not working anywhere and I had nothing I
had nothing my marriage was ending my
second marriage was ending we ended up
staying together but my marriage was
ending my wife was packing up again the
[ __ ] out I had no answers for production
I had no answers for spirituality I had
no answers for direction and inside of
lacking answers for what to do with the
only thing I could access was the facts
I was like it's the only gift I have to
myself right now is to actually just own
what is true and so you have men in that
place he'll be listening and women who
might be married to men are in
relational men are in that place then
you have another kind of man which is
the second place which is men who are in
really good lives and your lives to
become really good and you're listening
to this and you're going well yeah you
know I'm not [ __ ] up and you know I go
to cross for three times four times a
week and I'm feeling pretty good about
my body and feeling good about my
marriage my wife and I don't cheat I
don't have drug problems you know I go
to my kids soccer practice I go to
church on Sunday I meditate I do my
thing I'm like Gary you know [ __ ] you I
don't need this for my own Oh
you're the bigger risk oh yeah you're
the bigger risk sellout why because a
good man is the standard of greatness in
our society most men think that the
actual pursuit of life is to get to a
really good place and yet men inside of
our organization recognized really
quickly that getting to good and even
great is simply the next stage of
expansion which means no matter how good
things get you have one of two choices
you are not on a stationary bike you are
on a treadmill you stop [ __ ] walking
you will be spit off the back end of the
treadmill you have no choice there is no
stop and out of your boredom you will
start to destroy [ __ ] just like I did
cuz see the biggest risk is to the guy
that everybody's looking at and saying
oh man you got everything together to
the [ __ ] up guy with the drug problems
everybody's like that guy's [ __ ] up
you need some help he knows it everybody
around him knows it it's like somebody
in this situation popping steroids and
[ __ ] doing cycles alright all your
[ __ ] shredded your rip yeah I'm gonna
blow your heart up too and never never
buddy wants to point fingers at the guy
that eats at McDonald's three times a
day you're like well look at that ass
over here you're like well yeah and we
look at the guy over here who's mr.
esthetic who's 24/7 trying to look like
he's in a fitness show and he's [ __ ]
dying inside and at 24 years of age he's
[ __ ] dead which is all over in Europe
all over [ __ ] place in Europe come on
now aesthetics everywhere Oh [ __ ]
shredded bro no human body supposed to
look like that 24/7 you're not a goddamn
Greek statue like there are cycles
inside of the way the body's supposed to
operate so there's the hidden piece so
even I would say guys who are more risk
our business men who sit in a situation
where life is pretty good but you have
lost the sense of direction and purpose
you have accomplished what you knew you
could you have run past your blueprint
and you are currently sitting in a
decision and the decision is either I
choose to take on break down in order to
break through to a new plane of who I
could become or I will buy the direct
game of the universe and life be
compelled to do it and or I will do the
crazy [ __ ] which is you will get bored
and you will start watching your mind
wander
to other women you will start watching
your mind get distracted in business and
do [ __ ] that makes no sense
you will start finding a reason to make
chaos show up so that you can have a
purpose to build again or you could just
establish the game and go to the next
level
like wake up warriors an organization
we're a band them in and from around the
globe 27 countries committed to one
thing tell the truth and live the
Warriors way to having it all that a man
should have body being balancing
business the core for linked up together
we're not new at this we are the number
one training company in the world for
men period there's no one not Tony
Robbins or anyone else and go toe to toe
with what we do we train men we teach
men we know men we lead men but we lead
modern men so where we are in the modern
wisdom podcast talking to modern men who
might have gray on their beards you
might even have gray on your hairy ass
crack I don't even know but here's what
I can tell you if you're listening to
this show and you're getting insight
number one from an amazing young man
who's very about sounds like a goddamn
philosopher when I listened to him talk
he's like smartest [ __ ] and he shredded
you're probably jealous you're like it's
[ __ ] shredded he talks like a
philosopher he's a good-looking guy the
hell I wish I could have it well guys
why you're not plugged in here Bronk
because to be thirty years of age and
leading a podcast and having
conversation with people he's having
conversations with that's not easy it's
not it's not something that comes
without a price and without a sacrifice
and he does it for you so share the show
period listen to it give it to your
friend spread it around because this is
not easy I've run podcasts so many of
you get used to just downloading [ __ ] on
your phone you're like oh this is like
so easy I mean Chris just wakes up and
he shits a podcast out in the morning no
this takes work and it looks like he
might but you got that piece the other
piece is this we have available I'd love
to give you both books where your book
can be the man the book for free no no
junk in this if you're in Europe we ship
in there too we paid for just shipping
shipping yourselves like 15 bucks yeah
some people are god it's too expensive
no we offset it because some of the
books were shipping to Europe somewhere
shipping to Canada some worshiping a
Mexico somewhere shipping two miles down
the road from my offices yes we offset
the cost from my shipping and that if I
would love to get that message in your
world you can check that out by going to
work
come which is really the start it's the
start of a conversation
worst case scenario you'll enjoy the
movie that's there we have one-hour
documentary at war ebook calm or you can
watch learn more about it and for our
super aggressive men who are like listen
I'm you know I know any more than a book
you can watch a three-hour documentary
that we have found at warrior week calm
and there on that site you'll get to see
you'll get to see behind the scenes of
what actually happens at word week maybe
it's for you maybe it's not and if it's
for none of you and none of this and you
just want to tell me to [ __ ] off and you
wonder why I have a literal gun to like
flush my toilet it's not a real gun I
shoot bullets with a single water cannon
well at least you got a little bit
entertainment and you got another great
episode brought to you here by me and
Chris here on the wisdom podcast Thank
You Garrett man it's been an absolute
blast I really appreciate your time the
links to worry week be the man and
everything else will be in the show
notes below thank you very much for
coming on I know you're a very busy man
I appreciate it Chris thank you and by
the way you're a great interviewer I've
enjoyed being on your show today
seriously you have mad skills I do a lot
of these and I'm gonna be honest most
machete so you did great I enjoyed
hearing your philosophy I'm actually I
literally I was sitting right here and
my note I made on my phone during the
show I'm sinners like download your
podcast literally I'm gonna start
listening to it because you had you have
a lot to say I would encourage you to
not interview people sometimes and just
go off yourself
thank you like you got a man thank you
so much for having me on the show today
thank you dude bye-bye okay
[Music]
you